[Music]
[Applause]
all right
let's see make sure there's no raccoons
in here
[Applause]
[Music]
luke and nathan here with the outdoor
boys youtube channel and we're back at
our hand-built
bushcraft log cabin and we're working on
another project
we're building an outhouse that's right
we're building the brown throne the
squatty potty
palace of dookie the porta john we are
building
an outhouse and in addition to loads of
potty jokes we are also going to explain
to you
how to poop in the woods because we know
a lot of you guys wanted to ask
like you said right here if we can
[Applause]
have it i'm gonna be doing a lot of
digging
double enough we get dull put mouse
flaps
okay it's a lot of poo will fit in there
almost goes
to my waist
well if we dig the hole in deeper nate
could fall in and never get out
but i think it's time to go cut some
wood
i got a couple aromatic cedar trees that
are dead those are really nice because
they don't
rot very easily so that might be good to
use in my outfit
all right
[Music]
changed
[Music]
hey
[Music]
are you tired nathan yeah i'm tired well
it's about five o'clock so i think we
should make some dinner what do you
think
yeah i can't wait all right we'll get
some firewood together and build the
fire
and uh we're building out here and keep
working on burning down this stump
got a little cotton ball with some
petroleum jelly on it we're gonna use
that as our fire starter here
okay you got the blast match here just a
little ferrous rod with a
piece of steel makes nice big sparks
there we go
let's find a hot dog stick nathan i got
a big pile of little sticks over here
here we go
we've got some nathan's hot dogs for
nathan and me
all right there you go buddy you got
that
probably the simplest cheapest campfire
food you can make
that's really good see and then you hold
on to the butt like your hot dog
nathan's got me in stitches we brought a
watermelon along
and he named it aunt melanie after my
sister melanie
[Music]
what do you got there oh got a little
kinder egg for dessert
oh it is a toy little black cat there
look at that oh my goodness oh it's a
hazelnut rolled in chocolate
in a pool of frosting well nathan what
do you want to do now watch your movie
you want to just get in bed and watch a
movie all right i can agree with that
i'm pretty tired
take the lantern in there all right
shout out to all my uk peeps digestives
what
mmm chocolate how'd you get in the ice
and why aren't you frozen well good
morning
it's a little cold i think i might have
to get a fire started
[Applause]
good morning you ready for some
breakfast yeah pieces of wood stabbed
into this now the breakfast is over i
get nathan set up for online school so
uh
i think i'll have to get a little desk
and chair set up for him
oh our stumps almost burned through i
think we might be able to knock it down
his online school is gonna start in a
few minutes so
um i guess i'm gonna start taking
measurements for the outhouse
hey
um
put one more
[Music]
let's see can you use it a little big
huh
when daddy uses it i'll use it just like
this and when you need to use it
just go and put that on there and you
can adjust it however you like okay
that going to work all right good stuff
well there you go guys
it's not a porcelain throne but more of
a log
cabin yeah all right guys we got the
toilet done
but uh i think we're gonna break for
lunch and when we come back we're gonna
put up some walls and get a little bit
of a shelter built around this thing
all right why don't you pull out the
melon
aunt melanie nope
oh she did not survive the fall
yeah you want that campfire watermelon
it's pretty hard to beat on summer day
all right i'll give you guys one guess
what nathan wanted for lunch
he is a cup of noodle fiend
nathan's got his cup of noodle but i've
got a baguette some salami
some nice cheeses big marmalade it's
going to be a nice little lunch
okay
so
[Music]
i've lost
oh oh i'm tired
i think it's gonna work out though
what do you got there a new oh look at
that
i found him after daddy dug up something
yeah
that is so cool he's so pretty
well guys we got a good pile of wood
here but it's getting late it's almost
seven o'clock and we haven't had dinner
yet so
i'm gonna get the fire going and make
this boy some dinner
and uh we're gonna finish this project
tomorrow
right go
a little bit of gouda a little bit of
bread
we're just finishing up dinner and looks
like our outhouse has its first customer
here's the toilet paper buddy tell me
how it is
we want a review what'd you think
it's pretty good i really
think you should put like a wall deal
that's a good point i'll i'll see what i
can do about that
why don't you get changed and hop into
your sleeping bag
well the outhouse works very well all
right we're just going to get that
back wall up today and we'll be done
well first
gotta get some breakfast made
yes
[Applause]
we got some steel cut oatmeal with uh
raisins and strawberries here
we got nathan all set up for online
school so i'm gonna go
try to finish up the back wall of this
outhouse
daddy well there we go
she's all done look at this
that is a good looking outhouse
yeah looking good what do you think
is that good outhouse yeah i need to use
it all right go for it
all right now that we finished the
outhouse i promised you i would teach
you how to poop in the woods i'm going
to give you
my five best tips for pooping in the
woods after living in japan for several
years
and using traditional japanese toilets i
learned something
americans don't know squat about
squatting
when americans squat they like to go on
the balls of their feet with their heels
off the ground
this really makes it hard to balance an
asian squat
they stick their toes out and they put
their heels flat on the ground
well if you squat with your toes
pointing forward it's hard to get
down low so you pop up on the balls of
your foot if you pigeon toe
then you can squat down with your heels
flat on the ground
it's much more comfortable and you can
sit in that position for a much
longer time without losing your balance
it's a lot easier to maintain your
balance squatting down
if you're facing slightly downhill
sitting down and squatting for an
extended period of time is a bit hard on
your knees
use a small tree then you can go and
squat down
for a lot longer with good balance when
westerners sit down on the toilet a lot
of them
pull their pants and underwear all the
way down to their ankles which is fine
but when you're squatting don't pull
them down past your knees
if you pull your pants and underwear
down past your knees when you squat down
there's a good chance you're going to
tinkle or dookie in your underwear
all right guys let's talk toilet paper
if you're going to poop in the woods
use biodegradable toilet paper don't use
wet wipes and ideally
use the rv friendly septic system
friendly
toilet paper it decomposes much faster
so let me give you an example see this
pile of toilet paper
that's only one week old and you can see
how much it's decomposed
over here is a pile of toilet paper
that's about two and a half weeks old
and over there the stuff you can't even
see that's about two months old
so if you're in a place with a lot of
rain and humidity environmentally
friendly toilet paper will be gone in a
couple months
if you're in a desert environment it's
gonna sit around for a long time if
you're in a place where people hike or
camp make sure to bury or dispose of
your poo properly
you can either do this by pooing into a
honey bucket and throwing it away
or burying your poo and if you're going
to bury it dig the hole first and dig it
as deep as you can
poo in the hole then cover it up leaving
poo out in the open and not only is it
gross and attracts flies and stuff
but it also attracts animals so if
you're near a campsite you can track
raccoons and rats and all sorts of gross
stuff
if somebody in your group doesn't want
to squat in the woods a good hack is to
use a five gallon bucket
just line the bucket with a plastic bag
then put a pool noodle around the rim to
make it soft and to keep the plastic bag
in place
poo in the bag seal up the bag burn it
or throw it away
if you don't have a plastic bag you can
use a little bit of sand clay or
environmentally friendly kitty litter
and then once you've done your business
you can dig a hole and dump it deep in
there
one of the worst places i've ever had to
poo was on the tundra of alaska north of
the arctic circle
the gnats and mosquitoes were so thick
it looked like a brown haze about six
feet above the tundra
it was just insane how many bugs there
are and as soon as you pulled your pants
down they would get all over your bits
and just bite the crap out of them and
it would itch so bad
but if you try to spray bug repellent
where the sun don't shine it
burns so badly so uh
what we would do is go and find a little
bit of a null
uh when there was a breeze and point
your butt upwind
and then do your business and the breeze
would help keep the bugs off your bits
well there's three improvements i want
to make on this outhouse next trip
one uh i want to put a tarp over the top
so if it's raining
you can do your business without getting
dripped on and two i think i might bring
an old toilet seat
and just nail it to the top of this
toilet and if i do that i might convince
my wife to come out and join me here
and then finally i want to get a little
bucket of sawdust
to keep by the toilet so we can throw
that down there after we do our business
it'll help keep the smell down
and help keep the flies down which is
important i learned after going to the
bathroom in an outhouse in manly alaska
turns out there was thousands and
thousands of flies down in the hole
and as soon as i started pooing on them
they all tried to get out but my
bum was in the way and so all the flies
tried to climb through me to get out of
the
out of the outhouse and so i jumped up
because it's really gross and then they
started flying in my mouth and ears and
everything
and ever since that experience not
having flies
in your outhouse has become a higher
priority to me so
i'll have to go get that sawdust have
you had fun yeah
awesome all right we got the campsite
broken down and the log cabin buttoned
up until the next time we come out here
and we do new videos every saturday
morning so don't forget to click
subscribe and activate your
notifications
and if you guys want to see how we built
this log cabin i'll put links to that
video down below
but thanks for watching guys we'll see
you next saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching